in the wake of hamas's horrific surprise
attacks in southern Israel the Israeli
Army is preparing for a full-scale
ground assault of the Gaza
Strip on Friday the Israeli military
demanded the people of Gaza City move to
the southern part of The Enclave because
military operations would take
place there is a term that is often used
in the military called the center of
gravity uh it's a term that denotes
where all the strength of the enemy
emanates from and obviously in the case
of Hamas uh the center of gravity is
inside
Gaza Israel's goals for this operation
are three get the hostages back conduct
a retribution for the attacks and to
remove move Hamas as a force inside of
Gaza so that it will never be a threat
to Israel again Mark kimet is a retired
US Army Brigadier General who served in
Bosnia Kosovo and Iraq it's very
important to understand how small the
Gaza Strip is uh its border is 25 miles
along the shore and the border on land
runs for about 36 miles that's twice the
size of Washington DC the challenge for
the Iraq the Israeli Defense Forces as
they attack in is the terrain itself not
only is it small but it's heavily
populated throughout there are very few
open areas in Gaza uh and as a result
when you attack into Gaza it is not a
military operation with long range tanks
firing against each other uh every area
of
Gaza can be reached by weapons firing in
One Direction or the other so from the
moment the Israelis cross into Gaza
they're in somebody's gun s sits now how
would the Israelis attack their goal
will inevitably be the city of Gaza
looking at a map you would expect them
to come primarily through the center
here to cut cut off the city of Gaza as
well as use this little open area uh
between the populated South and the
populated North at first glance I would
expect them to come with their main
attack into and as near as possible to
the city of Gaza to try to isolate it
from the rest of the Gaza
[Music]
Strip General kimt believes a ground
Invasion could complicate the effort to
save the hostages Hamas terrorists took
into Gaza what is being asked for in a
fullscale Invasion urban conflict
uprooting Hamas leadership and bringing
back the hostages alive uh is not
something that's typically done by a
conventional Army they're not trained to
do that um and if you take a look at the
terrain inside of Gaza particularly with
the extensive tunnel system and the fact
that Hamas has had years and years to
prair defenses a ground Invasion would
actually risk the lives of those
hostages more than uh increase the
chances of them being brought out
alive zooming out General kimet sees
additional threats coming from hostile
forces in Israel's neighboring Nations
and territories going clockwise you
obviously have Hezbollah which is a
threat but not a major threat they would
probably attack directly south you've
got militant groups in Syria the typical
attack route is through the Golan
Heights or through Sheba
Farms obviously you have West Bank
militants which could attack uh towards
Tel Aviv but more than likely they will
make their focus towards
Jerusalem and even in the uh Sinai
Peninsula and here in Egypt there remain
a number of threats uh in the Sinai
itself primarily Al-Qaeda elements any
of these
organizations could be a threat to
Israel they would be distracting attacks
attempting to pull forces away from the
main battle down here in Gaza but now
that the Israeli forces are
mobilized I don't believe that they
would have the capability to be any more
than a distraction and not have any
consequence on the operations against
Gaza City zooming out still further
General kimet sees additional Regional
threats for the Israelis I think it's
important to understand the far threat
not just the near threat the popular
mobilization forces in Iraq some of them
have pledged fty to this to this fight
and even down here in Yemen the houthis
in Yemen believe it will be a
multipronged war and uh we could very
well see houthi involvement on the side
of Hamas in this fight I don't
necessarily believe that they will pose
as much of a military threat as they
would pose a diplomatic threat the
normalization efforts between Saudi
Arabia and Israel pretty much on the
Shelf uh the the the onun that was being
or day tant that was being developed
between Saudi and AR Arabia and
Iran probably on the
Shelf most important the street the
community community of Muslims in the
region the Uma the street is active
again and almost universally condemning
Israel for the attacks that they will
conduct into
Gaza I think the history of Israel since
1948 has been a series of conflicts that
in many ways resemble what we're seeing
here today uh perhaps not in scale
perhaps not in size but certainly an
tent uh whether it was the attempt to
destroy the state of Israel in 1948 the
67 attacks the 73 attacks the repeated
incursions into Gaza by the Israeli Army
sadly this is new in terms of its scale
it's new in terms of the tactics
employed by Hamas but it is 75 years old
in terms of what Israel has face as a
threat to their state since
[Music]